hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast
as you guys may recall a few months back
king david otw announced an amazing
giveaway for the xbox series x
while i'm proud to announce that the
iron lords podcast will once again be
giving away another console
at the end of this year and that console
will be a playstation
5. you heard correctly so
how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain
if you're already a member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this amazing console and if you
support us on both platforms
you have two ballots to win this amazing
console as you also have two ballots to
win
an xbox series x so if you're not a
member of the realm
what are you waiting for head on over to
patreon.com
go to the ironlord's podcast patreon
page become a member of the realm
to get your chance to win a playstation
5.
you can also join us on youtube iron
lord podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have
a ballot to win a playstation 5 console
and if you want to support us on both
platforms you'll have
two ballots for each system to win
either a playstation 5 console or of
course as king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lords podcasts are so
happy to bring to our community because
you guys give so much back to us
so again if you're not a member of the
realm yet what are you waiting for
go out join the realm on either patreon
or youtube and until next time i'll see
you at the round table